digamos que tengo una función en fx y
que esta función
fx va a ser x cuadrada menos 6 x más 8
muy bien entonces lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es ver cuál es el punto ce o
alguno de los puntos ce tales que la
derivada en ese punto coincide con con
la tasa de cambio promedio de esta
función en algún intervalo y digamos
para fijar ideas vamos a decir que va a
ser en el inem en el intervalo 2 coma
muy bien entonces esta función vamos a
definirla en el intervalo 25 claramente
esta función es continua verdad es un
polinomio así que esta función es
continua de hecho en cualquier número
real también es derivable en cualquier
punto x de la línea real de la recta
numérica muy bien entonces lo que vamos
a hacer es hallar hallar un punto ce que
se encuentre en el intervalo abierto 25
ok tal que tal que la derivada en ese
punto f prima en ce sea igual a la tasa
de cambio promedio de la función en este
intervalo que eso es f de 5 - efe dos
hubs s 2 se ve muy feo
efe de 2 entre 5 menos 2 muy bien y
sabemos que este punto debe existir pues
se se satisface el teorema del valor
medio verdad así que vamos a ver bueno
primero que nada quiero invitarte a que
hagas una pausa y que pienses tú cómo
encontrarías esta c para qué
esta esta igualdad se cumpla
entonces para poder hacer eso digamos
necesitamos calcular efe de 5 cuánto
vale efe evaluado en 5 entonces 5 al
cuadrado son 25 menos 6 por 5 son 30 más
8 y estos son 25 menos 30 son menos
cinco más ocho son tres muy bien cuánto
vale
efe 2 efe de 2 son 2 al cuadrado que son
4 menos dos por 6 son 12 entonces 4
menos 12 es menos 88 vale cero así que
esto de aquí va 3 - 0 entre 5 menos dos
que es 3 y esto vale 1 entonces
necesitamos hallar un punto tal que la
derivada en ese punto sea uno muy bien
así que quien es la derivada de esta
función
tenemos la derivada de la función efe
2x menos 6 muy bien y necesitamos que
esto sea igual a 1 queremos encontrar la
equis para que esta derivada sea igual a
1 entonces si sumamos 6 de ambos lados
tendremos 2x igual a 16 que es 7 y por
lo tanto x es igual a 7 medios muy bien
nuestro punto que estamos buscando son 7
medios así que el punto cox2 lo mismo es
igual a 7 medios y solo para que veas
que realmente estamos diciendo bien las
cosas vamos a hacer la gráfica para que
veamos cómo se ve esto entonces aquí
vamos a tener nuestro eje y
hey vamos a tener aquí el eje x al
parecer la gráfica se mueve sólo en
estos dos cuadrantes verdad el 1 y el 4
digamos que aquí está el 1 el 2 el 3 el
quizás vamos a quitar un poquito de esto
en el 4
y el 5
ahí está entonces sabemos que f en 5
estrés así que aquí en el 12 el 3
entonces por aquí 1 2 3 4 5 andamos por
aquí más o menos más o menos y sabemos
que en 2 vale 0 muy bien es uno de los
puntos donde cruza el eje x ahora sí si
nos fijamos bien en esta función la
podemos factorizar como x 2 x x menos 4
verdad la suma de menos 2 y 4 es menos 6
su producto es 8 entonces está bien esta
factorización y entonces sabemos que
además otro punto donde cruza el eje x
es en 4 entonces tenemos estos dos
puntos por donde pasa este tercero y por
lo tanto el punto digamos dónde tiene su
mínimo está justo en 3 ahora cuánto
valen 3 tendríamos
de 3 serían 9 menos 3 por 6 que son 18
ahí serían 9 menos 18 son menos 9 más 8
es menos 1 entonces aquí vale menos 1 y
aquí más o menos tenemos una idea de
cómo se ve nuestra parábola muy bien ahí
está y entonces se igual a 7 medios que
esencialmente son como 3.5 en 3.5 la
derivada debe coincidir con la pendiente
de esta línea con la pendiente de esta
línea y más o menos se ve que sí es
cierto verdad sí aquí han del 3 y medio
más o menos esta sería la pendiente de
la recta tangente en ese punto